all right thanks everybody for coming
this is the last session of the first
day of Qi P so in a big long day full of
really excellent talks and we'll top it
off with you know a little bit of a
casual evening so we're going to
introduce a little bit of software talk
a little bit about practical quantum
programming also introduce us and
ourselves so thanks for coming and we're
really looking forward to talking more
with you guys so I'll just introduce
he'll be who'll be speaking it'll be
it'll be me and two of my colleagues
today so my name is Wil Zhang I'm the
software and applications lead at a
startup called Righetti computing my
background is a real mix of hardware and
software in quantum computing so so I
started in superconducting circuits in
superconducting qubits messing around
calibrating trans mods in the lab and
then it seemed like trans bonds were
eventually going to get built and scaled
up and we're still working on that but
so I switched and did my PhD in quantum
algorithms in CS actually all the way in
category theory and quantum algorithms
so my background goes from calibrating
qubits in the lab to category theory for
quantum algorithms and it's been it's
been really fun journey and that kind of
spread has given a little bit of a view
to some of the stuff we'll talk about
today and my colleagues will also be
speaking a Robert Smith and Nick Rubin
who will introduce themselves when they
come on so we've already had 20 great
years of progress in quantum computing
both in hardware and in software from
the first original era cracking codes
first original qubits things in NMR the
first kind of round of quantum
algorithms everybody knows Shore's
algorithms growth algorithm and all
these kind of things but what's been
happening recently has also been very
very exciting and there's been two kinds
of shifts that have been very important
for the field and in particular for the
stuff that we do and the things that we
focus on one of those is that certain
implementations of quantum bits in
particular superconducting qubits have
gotten good enough that it makes sense
to try and scale them up and to do more
complicated kinds of algorithms in an
experimental way with them the second
big shift is a change on the algorithms
and software side so you know as of you
know five or six years ago when you do
back-of-the-envelope calculations for
things like shores you end up with you
know million gate fully fault tolerant
error correct
algorithms you know this kind of
performance will take a long time to get
with hardware but more recently there's
been an emergency of things that for the
purposes of this talk I will call
quantum classical hybrid algorithms
quantum error correction actually itself
is a little bit like this where there's
classical processes doing decoding and
also you know quantum measurements and
parity checks but there have also been
ways of doing quantum simulation of
systems ways of doing optimization
algorithms that have come about and in
particular there's been some ways of
maybe showing quantum supremacy in
near-term devices there's going to be a
talk about this on Friday that I really
encourage you guys to attend Sergio's
giving it that from the google group so
that has given some evidence to the idea
that actually with you know 50 to 100
noisy qubits we might be able to
demonstrate quantum supremacy for a
couple interesting problems we might be
able to start to try and do some
interesting quantum simulations even
with some noise so this is a really
really exciting time to to be working in
quantum computing so I'll talk about us
and so Righetti's a venture-backed
startup it's based in Berkeley
California
additionally four key beliefs that come
together and and the things we focus on
so we work with superconducting
microwave circuits we're trying to scale
them up make them bigger make them
better make them more performant we're
focused on near-term applications so
we're not waiting until having a very
very large fault tolerant machine we're
trying to see what we can do while we
still have physical qubits but we still
have a bit of noise so in particular
that means things like variational
quantum eigen solver squall wall the
quantum is it optimization algorithm and
also obviously testing quantum error
correction so building towards fault
tolerance is part of that and then
fourthly there's you know a lot of
people talk about this and you know
we're taking it seriously as well we
think that maybe the first quantum
computers will be Co processors that you
access over the cloud and so that's sort
of the model that we have in mind and
you'll see that in in a software they
were actually talking about and
launching today this is the company
itself so one of the picture in the top
left I guess I should describe this
we're at a theory conference that's a
superconducting circuits chip and and to
make it we've had to build up a team
about 50 moving 150 people across
fabrication quantum engineering which
for us is designing superconducting
circuits and also testing that
and calibrating them also the doing work
in the cryogenic systems and the control
electronics that are involved here and
then finally the fourth bucket is
quantum software and applications team a
lot of whom are actually here at Q IP
and of which I'm a member the last of
course plug is we're still growing and
we're hiring so anyone who has talked to
me about that we have a booth outside or
just grab any other getti people so I
think to focus what we're talking about
today there's been a lot of advances in
quantum algorithms it's been a lot of
advances in chips and now there's a need
for software tools to help us
investigate the next phase of quantum
computing quantum circuits are great
though they are typically programmed in
latex they do not scale that well to the
kind of large and complex things we
really want to run on stuff that we're
going to have in the next three to five
years
this is recognized it's actually been
recognized for a while but it's starting
to I think really really matter so there
have been some research and academic
projects things in C Haskell equipo de
Wecker tomorrow we'll be talking about
liquid Microsoft's excellent toolkit in
F sharp which you know uses a lot of the
sort of multi faceted things in that
language to do interesting things and
there's another kind of bucket of
software that's also worth talking about
which are tools in some some theorists
and modeling people use a lot of them in
Python like q-tip q infer which chris is
talking about as a poster number 63 in
that room if you want to learn about Q
infer it's for Bayesian inference and
things like a Python package that does
gates that tomography for you to help
you calibrate you know your chips so
there's a little bit of an ecosystem of
software tools that are that are
starting to grow and I think this is
really really important as we start to
move into the into the next phase and
start to care not just about the scaling
of algorithms but what the actual gate
count is on which qubits they are
applied how we compile them and how they
perform and so this is very very early
days and I want to just kind of throw
out one more thing there also needs to
be more foundational research and one
thing that we're also announcing today
we're really excited about is you guys
might know Peter Sellinger he his group
did a lot of additional work on on
clipper a lot of compulsory compilation
algorithms and one thing that we're
doing is we're actually funding a
postdoc with Peter if you'd like to work
on the foundations of quantum
programming languages he's working on
something called proto clipper kind of
really looking at the foundations of QP
ELLs from the ground up
sent him an email because he's got to
post our position and you can talk to me
about that over him so these are really
early days for thinking about what it
means to practically program a quantum
computer and I want to introduce Forrest
which is our internal toolkit so this is
all in draft I really think like we
should think about high level languages
we should think about instruction set
architectures everything from the bottom
to the top but it's all really in draft
it's it's not like we can sit down and
write down a spec for what's needed to
program quantum computers in next three
to five years but we should take a start
so this is a this is one draft that
we've been using internally and there's
a few parts to it
so as I mentioned it takes seriously
this this idea that a lot of people have
about the coprocessor model about the
cloud exits process and model so there's
a couple pieces of software on the
client side I'll go through them quickly
so the first is a quantum instruction
language called quill we'll talk we'll
talk more about that and built on top of
that there are some Python libraries now
called PI quill which lets you generate
these circuits and run them on top of
that there are some examples in the repo
that we're calling Grove where we've
looked at some of the near-term
algorithms that we've internally studied
and that you know we'd liked a lot more
people to to work with and add things
there so this then runs in an asura
client-server model on either a quantum
virtual machines use our name for a
simulator that takes in pool code and
simulates the action of a quantum
processor we're on a real quantum
computer so we've released this a few
days ago the website is for stereo comm
it's a tool tool kit and an API for
experimental client programming I'm
really excited about starting make it
available and so what this completely
means is that everything in the top
bucket and that client side is all open
source and github under the Apache v2
license and there's some all the
documentation is hosted on read the docs
you can check that out there and you can
pip install it we'll talk more about
this stuff soon and it also means that
the server side which we're still
working on a lot is now open for private
beta quantum virtual machine signups and
you can sign up on for Stargate comm to
get a key to work with that
so the idea is that and these are the
things that we've used force for
basically the idea is the forest helps
you write quantum algorithm study
quantum algorithms and program quantum
hardware so internally we've done
everything from you know writing vqe
examples and instances to kind of
extending them in some particular ways
to studying quantum algorithms under
noise studying how things like these
quantum supremacy results will vary
under different kinds of device
connectivity's and gate sets and
architectures and also to you know
really run pull code on superconducting
quantum chips this is a lot and it's
more than any one team of research can
do and it's more than we can do in one
go there's so much to do that we're
really excited to make this available to
the community to play with and kind of
build on this next draft as we all try
to get together to really get to a place
where we have tools to do these things
so the quick overview for what the
workshop would be today again it's like
pretty informal so Robert will hop on
and and give a quick overview of quill
itself this sort of pseudo spec for the
language and the quantum aspect machine
which is the mathematical structure that
quill targets then I will run some
quantum circuits on a superconducting
qubit because that's always fun
and then Nick will hop on and talk a
little bit about the Python libraries
that we have built on top of pike will
in a couple different areas that we
think are really important for a near
term quantum programming then we'll
break up they'll be drinks demos will
have to Paterno books you guys can play
in the environments play with the
software break it all those sort of fun
things and we'll talk about the quill
bots later so I'm happy to introduce my
colleague Robert will talk a little bit
about quill and the quantum effect
machine that it targets
[Applause]
hello everyone my name's Robert Smith I
work as a compiler engineer at riggidy
computing one perhaps interesting thing
about me is that I don't actually have a
quantum background so my background is
more in software engineering and sort of
mathematical and expert mathematical
software and experimental mathematics
and coming to Righetti has been
interesting kind of getting my my toes
wet with quantum computing and kind of
having a perspective of quantum
computing that is really software
oriented so I want to talk a little bit
about quill in the quantum abstract
machine which is kind of the basis for a
lot of the tools that we've built so
quill is kind of first and foremost a
very portable description of classical
quantum computations that can target
really sort of any machine any gate
based Universal machine not necessarily
superconducting qubits although that's
of course what we work with but it
doesn't target our hardware in
particular it's portable across really
any platform quill is also foundational
so what I mean by this is that quill
doesn't actually try to encapsulate
every single possible abstraction that
has been developed in the quantum
computing community so for example
things like circuit reversal or the
construction of Oracle's or gate
compilation or so on and so forth aren't
actually included in the quill language
itself but rather these are tools that
you can build on top of quill and quill
will sort of always provide a stable
foundation for that the most important
bit about quill may be second to its
portability is the fact that it's a
hybrid language classical quantum hybrid
language and so the best way I think to
describe this is actually through
something we're all familiar with which
is a circuit here I have a circuit for
quantum teleportation
and quantum teleportation of course has
these these quantum bits to it with
Hadamard gates and C not gates and so on
measurement but there's a part of the
circuit which is a little less well
defined these measurements and the
classical bits and something happens
with these bits but the circuits don't
really make that well-defined and so
will makes this well-defined and I'll
talk about that shortly first I want to
delve into the sort of abstract program
model of quill not really the the
practical way to view quill but kind of
the the theoretical foundations that
that allow you to really understand
what's happening under the hood so quill
is really a syntax for something called
the quantum abstract machine which is
just a purely mathematical device that
consists of some state in quill is a
syntax for instructions that that try
that transition on this state so there
are really three types of states that
the quantum abstract machine has there's
the quantum state of course your set of
qubits or your wavefunction there's a
classical state which is just a set of
bits and then the execution state what I
mean by that is when you're going
through a program there needs to be some
notion of sort of where you are in the
program and that's encapsulated by this
state people familiar with just normal
CPUs might be familiar with the idea of
a program counter that's a very similar
concept here on the right I have an
example quilt program I had a Mardon
qubit 3 a measurement of qubit 3 into a
classical bit numbered 4 and then a jump
instruction jumping to a label called
end depending on the value of a
classical bit I want to walk through
this program and talk a little bit about
how that affects the quantum abstract
machines state so the state can it
consists of this quantum states I
classical state C and execution state
Kappa and the quantum abstract machine
always starts off in a zero stage the
quantum state is a zero state the
classical bits are all zero and the
program counter execution state starts
off of course at the start of your
program so we kind of see that in that
first starting box there
and after we execute a Hadamard on qubit
three of course the quantum state is
going to change or if Hadamard on any on
any qubit is going to change is going to
change the state so we see there I have
a little red circle around around sigh
and size zero has become sy one
indicating that it's changed state I
didn't put a circle around the Kappa
there although when you incur when you
change instruction of course the
instruction counter is going to
increment but it's our sort of trivial
change of the instruction counter so I'm
just ignoring it in the first in the
first diagram if we move on to the
measure this is a much more interesting
instruction one it's a classical quantum
instruction meaning it's an instruction
that affects the quantum state but it
gives us feedback and allows us to sort
of observe its results by way of the
classical memory so here because it's
not deterministic we may measure the
qubit as a 0 or a 1 and so we get this
branching structure in the state if we
measure 0 then we'll deposit that in the
classical memory in classical bit number
4 in which case nothing has really
changed because everything started as 0
or in the case that we measure 1 we
deposit that an address for in the
classical state does change so you can
see that marked on both circles that
both classical and quantum state are
changing the last part and this is a
very different feature provided by quill
that I think is very unlike a lot of
other sort of quantum languages out
there which is the sort of native
support for classical control so here
I'm saying that I want to jump to a
particular part of a program depending
on whether the value in address 5 in our
classical memory is 0 or 1 so in this
case the jump when instruction there are
other jump instructions but jump 1 says
jump to the end when address 5 contains
the one bit or true value and as such we
can see in the diagram that Kappa
changes if we jump or Kappa will just
increment if if the bit is 0
this is like I said just a very
convenient way of thinking about the
abstract machine and it's kind of
something that should kind of be be in
the back your mind when you program
quill but I actually want to go through
a sort of more practical example that
talks about the strengths of quill is a
practical language for doing
computations so here I have a sort of
cartoon of a of a quantum processor with
some instructions to execute and on the
bottom I have some classical memory
there are two cells there that don't
have a number you can think of them as
having zero but just for illustrative
purposes I emptied them because we're
going to change the memory there if we
iterate through this program Hadamard on
0 scene out of 0 1 constructing a bell
state that's going to change the quantum
memory but then we do a measurement on
these qubits
cubed 0 and qubit one we're going to
deposit them in the classical memory so
we see here when you do measure qubit 0
into classical address seven we've
deposited it in this case we measured a
one and we've deposit that in the
classical memory being a bell state of
course if we measure qubit one we should
get the same result and indeed we see
that we have that and then we have this
last instruction called wait this isn't
a very computer scientific instruction
in the sense that it doesn't really have
some nice semantics it's just a more
practical device for synchronizing your
quantum computations with your classical
computer so wait actually says to stop
or halt computation on the quantum
computer and transfer control to your
classical processor so our classical
processors is using the quantum
processor as a coprocessor and
computation can resume on the classical
processor there are lots of different
ways this can be implemented depending
on the implementation of the quantum
processor it could be implemented with
interrupts or or some other mechanism
but whatever the mechanism we transfer
control over to the classical processor
in the classical processor itself can
access memory that is in particular this
classical memory so we see here we're
doing in this sort of pseudo Python code
if the bit at three plus the bit at
seven if the sum of those is two then
maybe we set some theta parameter
because we're doing some vqe loop or
something like that
and we can do any classical processing
based off of that data and furthermore
we can set data back in those classical
registers for the quantum processor to
use so in this case the quantum
processor in the classical processor
sort of have this sort of the symbiotic
computational relationship and as a
computation sort of evolves both can
help one another where either of them is
better I won't belabor the formal
details of everything we have a white
paper that is updated I don't know if it
has reached the archive quite yet if it
hasn't it should be you know by the end
of this week which is which you can find
their practical quantum instruction set
architecture it goes through all the
mathematical details of the instruction
set and the and the semantics of each
instruction and a little bit about
practical implementation of the machine
especially as the way Righetti has
implemented it i want to cap off and
actually go through and go back to that
circuit that i showed at the start of my
section which is the classical are the
quantum teleportation circuit which you
can find in any textbook and kind of go
through how that actually would manifest
itself in the cool programming language
so here I have this def circuit def
circuit and quill is a construction to
kind of make reusable functions in some
sense so def circuit teleport a Q and B
that says that it takes three qubits as
arguments and we can later instantiate
it as you see at the bottom teleport 0 1
and 5 if we're doing a quantum
teleportation with qubits 0 1 and 5 so
Alice's cube are Alice's ancilla is
labeled Q here Alice's qubit is a and
Bob's qubit is B and there's sort of
three logical sections to the circuit
there's a construction of the bow state
which we can kind of see this
correspondence here very sort of direct
translation there's the measurements
which is the actual sort of
teleportation part
which is a construction of another pair
Bella pair with the ancilla
and then the measurements but I want to
pause here and say that the measurements
aren't just these they're not just
measurements they're measurements whose
results are being deposited back into
this classical memory which is why I've
annotated the the circuit up there the
little measure boxes with 0 and 1 we're
saying when we measure this deposit the
result in address 0 and when we measure
Alice's qubit deposit the result in
address 1 this becomes useful for the
third part which is a sort of
generalization of what the circuit
actually provides so here in order to
implement sort of classically controlled
gates instead of making a dedicated
functionality in the quilt language for
the notion of a classically controlled
gate instead we use the concept of of
control flow classical control flow
within quilt to to supersede that notion
so here you can see that we we can skip
the X gate on Bob's qubit or skip the Z
gate on Bob's qubit depending on whether
the bit in address 1 or address 0 is is
1 or 0 so the last thing to sort of
iterate about this is that the classical
control is actually arbitrary so here
we've we've superseded the notion of
classical a classically controlled gate
using a jump but in fact we can jump
anywhere in the program we can have sort
of all of these notions that we we get
for free and classical computation like
loops and branching and so on as the
same in our quantum program and this is
something that can be implemented
efficiently in a quantum processor
especially with the help of technologies
like FPGAs and so on so I'd actually
like to move in and just show a couple
examples of kwill actually running just
to kind of solidify the points so here I
have a notebook right here that that is
Jupiter notebook but we've modified it
to actually run quill so it does not run
Python code here runs just straight
quill code
and this is something that that people
will be able to play with afterwards so
I'm not going to go through the entirety
of the notebook but I want to show a
couple examples if we execute this
identity gate on cubed zero of course
nothing should happen and we see that
the wave function remains in the zero
State
the amplitudes of the wave function are
in typical sort of lexicographic
ordering of the basis elements in
classical memory itself hasn't changed
we haven't done any measurements we
haven't done anything to actually change
the memory to give a little a more
complicated example that's not too
complicated an X Gate on 0 this is the
act of kind of flipping to the opposite
pole on the Bloch sphere so we see our
wave function has changed to be in the
one state we can do of course multiple
gates we can demonstrate measurement if
we flip to the opposite pole of the
Bloch sphere we see and we do a
measurement on that qubit into address
zero we see that we indeed got a 1 as
our first qubit something that's
important here is that when we measure a
qubit we are doing a projective
operation but the state of that qubit
actually is maintained through
computation so the qubit isn't reset or
anything like that if you project into
the 1 state for example the qubit will
stay in the one state for as long as as
long as you don't you know perform
further operations on it and I think
this is another differentiator from from
for example the circuit diagram where it
sort of implies that this qubit somehow
turns into a bit but here in quill the
qubit stays a qubit and you can further
modify its state its measurement is just
recorded in classical memory I'll skip
down and show an example of a bell pair
a Hadamard on qubit 0 and a C naught on
0 & 1 we see here if you look at the
wave function the first film in the last
element have equal probability if you
square those and everything you'll get
50% and we didn't have any measurements
here so our classical memory state is 0
we can define new gates you can see the
definition of a sort of simple gate
right here
the
negative Hadamard another more complex
gait definition a gate that's actually
parameterised by some by some parameter
here we have a rotation gate an X
rotation parameterize by theta which is
built-in but just for demonstration
purposes it's here and then the the
construction of circuits which I showed
you and then this last example is one
where we have this control flow so if we
look here we're jumping depending on
this this sort of first line here
jumping to label one depending on the
value in classical address zero since
it's zero in its state it's going to not
jump but if we intentionally use a true
the true instruction in quill which just
changes the classical memory to a one
bit it's sort of it's a constant
function but that forces a classical
address to be one then that jump will be
taken and we see that the classical
memory has a one bit in the in the
second element so this is just to
provide a little taste of quill but I
actually want to give the stage back to
give the stage back to will to perhaps
show more interesting use of quill
alright so it's good
I got the foundations right so we can
pick up a little bit and do two things
at once next so I'm just going to talk a
little bit more about using Python and
pike wheel to generate cool code and I'm
gonna do it in the context of running on
a real cubed so what's going to happen
now in this demo is we're going to go
from a pike but piece of pipe pool code
in Python in a jupiter notebook that
itself is going to compile down into
quill code two little instructions that
are then going to be compiled into
waveforms that go down to the bottom at
least refrigerator that run on a
superconducting circuits chip back in
Berkeley in particular this one in this
fridge one of our fridges in Berkeley
this is the chip with a little bit of
stuff blurred and that's the qubit and
that we're going to run on so what we're
going to do with pike will is we're
going to build up to running state
tomography on this qubit jump into
notebook and do so the first two things
we're going to do here again here's the
picture we're going to import from pike
wheel so this is what you would pip
install the forest connection library
you'd import this thing called a program
object I'll talk about that they'll
import some nice gates that we have a
standard and this is just for printing
and so then we'll connect to a you know
current device we're still working on it
it's got a few bugs and then you just
build a program so in this case we'll
build two programs one has the identity
gate one the ex gate and we can run them
on on the qpu in Berkeley and get back
just the index of the qubit and then the
thresholded state that we get back which
which matches so what we're doing here
is we're constructing a Python object
this pipe this pipe wall sort of program
object which then outputs into quill and
so this is nice because we can
manipulate the program object separately
from the program that's running we can
do things like compilation on it and we
have the you know the full advantage of
everything you can do in python to mess
with the program before outputting into
the intermediate representation so a
couple interesting examples that are
sort of more specific to running on real
hardware and are throwing in arguments
like you know turning off the threshold
entire to rotation going into the middle
of the Bloch sphere and if I don't
threshold this is sort of the
centage chance of it being in the
excited state a little bit off from
50-50 and but there's also other things
that you would imagine getting back from
a real Sweden qubit circuit and that
people will actually I think play with
and that we would like to encourage
people to think about what they would do
if they had access to this extra data so
things like the real physical amplitudes
and phases are the covariance matrices
and the kind of things that come out
that aren't just thresholded bits so
we're going to use quill now to write to
run some Rabi oscillations with some
parametrized programs and so what I'm
going to so Rabi oscillations are you
know just iterating through a series of
rx rotations of different angles so I'm
going to construct a list of those
programs starting with you know minus PI
to PI so 15 of them and each of these is
just taking from the standard gate
library some are Y these are
parameterize by some theta and then you
just pass in some target qubit build
them up into a Python list which is what
we have here etc and then running them
on the qpu is just running through each
iterating through each of the programs
and in this case I want the raw data to
come back because I'm going to actually
show and plot it against amplitudes not
plotted against zero one and we can just
plot so this is you know starting at
minus PI on the Bloch sphere moving
authorities starting in the excited
state moving down to the ground state
and then looping back up and if this
were to continue this would just be Rabi
oscillations and so we can look at
measurement physics in the IQ plane and
this is fun to kind of talk to two
theorists about a little bit so when you
measure a superconducting circuit when
you measure a real qubit you don't just
get back a bit you get back like I was
showing there some amplitude and some
phase and you can sort of look at what
the clusters that those form which are
then how it will be threshold to turn
into bit values so in this example I'm
running 10 programs that are just the
identity gate on this qubit and 10 that
are just the identity of the ex gate on
this qubit
what was done 9/10 and woo that's what
you get for the live demo anybody
somebody diagnosed what's going on here
anything so this is a switching behavior
and so we actually have sort of three
pseudo clusters here so the bottom one
is the ground state and then these two
pink ones or what happens when I apply
the xscape so there's actually not just
one cluster here so we can threshold and
we can give back one here but there's
actually kind of some kind of
measurement based switching that's
happening so there's more complex
behavior that's in quantum circuits that
isn't that complicated to percolate up
to the programmer and might be useful so
it's kind of an interesting thing to to
demo and show so we have another cubed
on this chip we can run will code on
multiple qubits in this case you know an
X and a Y and X to the next returns in
both back to the ground state and if we
apply an X to one and an X half to the
other we run the random probabilistic
demo live and we wait oh good this made
it easy for me and so it's it's pretty
simple because you're working in Python
to build up you know in just a couple
lines what stage market looks like in
Pikeville and so what you do here is you
have some input program that you're
trying to do tomography on so this is
the quantum circuit and at the end of
that circuit you're going to you know
apply all of your different rotations
and measurements so that you can do the
full tomography and get the density
matrix so those you know those are the
series of effects and preparations I'll
just click this off running it's going
to run a bunch of circuits and so we'll
loop through each of these these gates
will wrap them into a pipe or program
object will append the prepend excuse me
be the program that we're trying to do
tomography on I will just loop through
them and then we'll plot the data so in
this case we're looping through each of
these little very very tiny coil
programs and then plotting so here I ran
the Run kick these off while I'm talking
here we ran the identity gate so nothing
and you know we end up in the ground
state when we look at the results of our
state tomography and here I'm running
the ex-gay program so we'll just do
tomography on the excited state and get
back the density matrix and we can do
the same thing with an X hat so the
reason I wanted to show this is that
quill is actually really really simple
and some degree Pikeville is really
simple this looks like in some degrees a
complicated stack but I think there are
ways of making this kind of programming
simple enough that we can actually start
to build on top of it the really complex
tools that are needed to come up with
new quantum algorithms that work that
show supremacy that do things that
people care about and that are also
valuable so here's the in this case the
tomography we get for the x over 2
so yeah so as I said you know it's
pretty simple to use a hypo library to
run single qubit circuits to you to run
things like Robbie one thing it was
interesting about the Robbie example we
gave is we didn't tune up each of those
gates separately we just looped through
the list and applied them using
dynamically tuned up gates you know we
saw these additional IQ plane
measurement physics a little bit more
information that can happen when you
have physical qubits and you might care
about when you're programming things
that are physical qubits and we're and
within a couple lines of Python part of
state tomography but again this is just
the simple kind of building blocks and I
think what's really interesting about
the stack and the kind of research tools
that I think are really important for
for you guys are the applications and
things that can be built on top and this
is Pikeville and Grove and so for this
I'm gonna I'm going to turn over the
lectern to my colleague Nick Rubin hi
everyone I'm Nick in the lot remaining
like 20 minutes or so I'm going to go
over to libraries that sit on the top of
the stack will gave a introduction to
how PI quill and quill can kind of be
used to go down to interrogate what's
happening with the physics below and I'm
going to talk a little bit about how to
use the stack to go up and kind of study
quantum algorithms and use the qvm
simulator so a little bit about my
background I'm actually a chemist I
specifically quantum chemistry an
electronic structure and so I studied
methodologies to examine tangle meant in
molecules specifically with variational
to RDM methods and so one of the what
I'm going to talk about is how what was
the guiding principles in developing
Pyke will and grove so before I jump
into that actually what we're targeting
as we'll mentioned our near-term quantum
algorithms and so here's a list of some
of the things that are in that family
when I mean near-term I'm talking about
devices that are between 3 to 100 noisy
physical qubits what lives in that area
our variational quantum eigen solvers
specifically developed for chemistry
quantum approximate optimization and
then serving as a validation for error
correcting codes and this kind of long
unruly
list of citations is kind of just to
show that we there's a lot of work going
on in this between industry and academia
okay so for the rest of this I'm
actually going to be jumping back and
forth between then these slides and some
notebooks to demonstrate Pike well and
how we interact with the qvm but just as
as starting off this is the variational
quantum eigen solver and so at its core
variational core maghen solver is
finding an eigenvalue of a of a matrix
it actually it's very useful for very
large matrices and so really what it is
if you kind of look at it is it's
functional minimization where you have
some on sots and that unsought is the
wave function and then you're using the
quantum computer as a coprocessor to do
expectation value measurement this is
sitting in a classical optimization loop
which is changing your parameters for
that on sots
so my pedagogical example is something
actually quite simple let's say that we
have a non sots for a probability
distribution that's a Gaussian and you
see this little video I have here I have
some Gaussian that I'm sampling from
calculating the expectation value
against this quadratic function here and
then there's a classical optimization
loop that is changing the parameters of
that Gaussian the mean and the variance
and so as we expect it moves towards the
center of this quadratic potential and
gets very very thin to minimize the
expectation value this is useful in
quantum chemistry
now using something that's a little bit
more complicated as our own thoughts and
many-body expansion relates a couple
cluster and what Pike will provides is a
way to easily construct these things and
then output quill and right here we have
a short simulation of hydrogen binding
and so let me jump into the notebook to
kind of describe some of the
functionality of Pike well
okay so just as a reminder we're looking
at on these zoom in so it's a little
easier to see we're looking at these two
top libraries at the top of this stack
so something that you might want to do
as a kind of develop if you're looking
to develop algorithms so commonly I want
to encode some problem in some
Hamiltonian and use that Hamiltonian and
there as the generator for some unitary
one one of the things that I might want
to start out doing is representing the
language of quantum chemistry namely
Fermi Onyx and quantize operators into
something in the polygroup one way to do
that is join the join finger
transformation which I write down here
and so we're just checking parity with
these z strings here and then doing a
raising operator and with Pikeville we
provide a little computer algebra
package for for Poly's that lets you
easily construct something like this and
so here we're just doing a creation
operator and I'll just print through and
we see if we actually do a creation on v
we we do construct the create the
correct object in the poly group and so
we have our Z string here and then our
raising operator but we can do much more
complicated things we don't have to just
do something simple here we can write
down our favorite Hamiltonian the
Hubbard model though it is very simple
there's lots of as everyone knows
there's lots of interesting physics I
wrote some helpers here too to kind of
do some does this function here that
does the creation annihilation operators
so that's just I'll let import that and
we can just directly write down our
Hamiltonian and so you go through these
loops we define how many sites we have
we define the interaction parameters for
this thing and we just fill up our
Hamiltonian and these are poly objects
that are sitting in Pikeville and we can
see that we put this out we get the
Hamiltonian represented as some poly sum
so some sum of sums in poly group okay
so I mentioned that this was very useful
for doing variational quantum eigen
solver and one of the things that we
provide and drove our algorithm library
is functionality to do this and so
there's a lot of Python here but what
it's really doing I'll just click
through and then tell you about it
is is doing a lot of classical
pre-processing to things that are in
chemistry like molecular integrals and
so on but really all the functionality
is there and so I can represent my
Hamiltonian by a bunch of paulie's
import some-some Grove and then actually
some modules from Grove and then just
run vqb as a loop and here we're just
doing this live is doing hydrogen at
some particular separation and then at
the end we get the correct energy and
you could look at you know
reconstructing the state sampling from
this complicated thing there's lots of
stuff you could do let me jump back to
the size ok so that hubber model I
mentioned it's I wanted to really just
demonstrate that there's you can
interface with a lot of other packages
you can do complicated things you can
easily go and pull pull data from other
quantum chemistry packages and so this
is an example this graph that it just
appeared is the Hubbard linear Hubbard
model looking at that unitary couple
cluster on sots versus the u parameter
and the energy and each line is a
different method so like mean feel the
classical couple cluster unitary a
couple cluster and then the exact
solution another thing that comes
standard in the library it specifically
in Grove is our implementation of the
quantum approximate optimization
algorithm we have maxcut written by
default as a module but it also will
accept any cost function and any driver
and so as people start playing with our
borrowing ideas from the annealing
community we can look at driver
Hamiltonians that commute with the cost
function so we can encode constraints
into that and so this example here on
the slide is just showing you max cut on
a ring or the ring of disagrees at P
equals 1 the shortest version of this
and so those two tall lines on the graph
there are actually the correct by
partitioning of the nodes and you can
actually increase that and get the right
answer and this is all simulated with
the with forest and n PI quill so this
is just the actually I'll jump out again
and kind of show you that that
functionality that we actually have
one of the nice things about sitting in
a Python environment is that you can
easily construct any graph or any cost
function with Pikeville and just use
what we have and so if you're oh I just
generated a random graph and out of that
I can just print the circuit that you
would get out from the QA Oh a algorithm
and so this is quite long doing
variational I can solver with some some
minimizer as possible and we can do this
up to about 20 cubits on our QP M
[Music]
and so this is the last example slide
that I'd like to show we've talked a lot
about kind of simulating down but I also
wanted to to kind of point out that we
can actually go up and interface with a
lot of other things that would use these
as kind of code or use this idea of a
quantum computer as a coprocessor and so
one of the applications as a chemist I
see is using variational quantum eigen
solver or phased estimation with other
quantum chemistry algorithms and so one
that we looked at was density matrix
embedding is the summary it actually is
just a way to take an arbitrary law
arbitrarily large quantum system
discretize it and actually figure out
what the correct apart single particle
effective embedding potential is and so
for the Hubbard model you can study an
infinite system and actually get very
very good answers another thing that you
can do that we were just playing with
was what is a good mapping between
physical indices and qubits on your
lattice and so I showed you Jordan
vikner representing fermionic operators
to some element in the poly group before
there are other ones that are out there
like Ravi kitaev and what those do
actually is posit a structure of
connectivity of qubits on your on your
actual quantum device but that actually
might not represent reality ravi tative
parity graph here actually doesn't
represent a lattice of qubits that maybe
is compatible with the surface code and
so you can will be noticed was that this
actually lives in a family of transforms
you can use that your actual cubic
conductivity to represent the graph the
parity graph and so we'll be putting
that both of these things on archive
soon and just the show here actually the
number of qubits on the neck or the
x-axis here is the number of qubits on
the bottom the y-axis is the gate counts
and we actually see that when you
consider doing arbitrary entanglement on
your on your lattice you actually are
saving by using this transformation the
transformation that's including
information of the qubit layout so here
we're actually saving in the number of
swaps that we have to do ok so just as a
summary Pike will lets you
programmatically generate and manipulate
coil programs it comes with a little
computer algebra package so you can
easily do do a lot of things like
coding your problem simplifying Polly's
and things like that it comes or it
comes with Grove and so there are some
things we've implemented in there like a
very flexible and robust version of
variational quantum eigen solver qaq AOA
and then the normal samples like
teleportation Q of T and phase
estimation and also manages your
connection to Righetti forest and so
when you have your beta key you can go
and run on the q vm and eventually real
hardware and so just to be clear this is
actually really one of the reasons that
actually I really like Python is that it
has a lot of really large community and
it's really easy to install and so you
can pip install here the libraries
they're actually up now on pi pi and go
get them and I think we do have pretty
good documentation and we try to be very
responsive to any issues that are raised
so I think with that I'll turn it back
to will so this is the stack we're going
to throw you guys some notebooks in a
second and a link to pull up some things
so you can play with it yourself but we
want to take a quick break we've got
everybody to take if you guys have
questions now and before you play with
stuff we're also going to be around to
ask question commands questions later
anything no you guys just want to play
with stuff okay what's up
yeah so we don't have a lot of gate
circuit and compilation stuff
yeah I'll repeat the question the
question is do you have circuit
compilation or circle optimization stuff
in Pikeville now and we haven't added
that yet and we like be happy to work
with anybody to add that anybody has
ideas about how to add that which
algorithms we should add there's a lot
of really great ones out there and we
really want to so yeah on the qvm up to
about 20 20 20 yeah yeah but you know if
your circuits really long you'll notice
yeah so the qvm implementation we have
now is like doesn't do density matrix
evolution but if something one thing is
nice about having a quill spec is that
you know the spec for that so if anyone
wanted to write a density matrix
emulator which is one thing we're
thinking about working on as well but
haven't had time yet you know how to do
that and that's something that we would
find very useful to do next States
now I just do the Purdue projective
measurement it'll just do a projective
measurement on the on the one yeah hey
yeah so it stores the whole state but it
applies the it doesn't like tensor up
the interval so this is about the qvm
implementation so the question is does
the qvm store the entire state and a
little bit about how that how the
quantum virtual machine operates and so
it stores the whole state but it doesn't
apply or tensor up all of the gates and
unit Ares it applies the unit Ares in
place in kind of that typical sort of
efficient way yeah do you want any more
yeah yeah so the wave function
representation is dense it tries to be a
little bit clever about looking at your
quill program so if you're not using
certain qubits or if you decide to index
your qubits in a certain way it's going
to use the minimum number of qubits
possible when we say 20 cubits generally
we're talking about just on a normal
laptop normal sort of developers laptop
not on any big cluster or you know
supercomputer or anything like that we
do store all two to the you know n
qubits all the amplitudes and generally
we found that to be most useful as
opposed to any particular sparse
representation because a lot of the
computations that we're doing eventually
is entangling all the state so we found
that the most practical practically
useful thing but yeah if any I mean
we're one of the reasons for opening
this up is people have ideas about how
to write better simulators
that'd be great like I think community
wise if we had one really really great
distributed open-source simulator that
you could then build like kind of the
more abstract programming tools on that
would be awesome so anybody who wants to
work on that with us like please to
opportunity
yeah
yeah so we don't use it for everything
and we're actually finding them as we
were putting together this is the first
demo that we've done live of running of
running qubits and in putting together
this demo we've started to think that
we're actually going to use it a lot
more internally as our front end it's
sort of a bit of dog fooding and but you
know for more complicated tune up you
know things like gates at tomography and
stuff like that we haven't done it
through pike will and but we could and I
actually think we might just migrate to
using this as a front end even for our
experimental tune-up in calibration oh
yeah I'm going to talk about recursion
so the question was key influence
recursion so the quill language itself
doesn't include any notion of like a
recursive function call so that kind of
brings a question how do you implement
something like QFT which is recursive
this is part of the reason why we we
built pike will is because while python
has this natural notion of recursion of
course and implementing a circuit in
pike well recursive circuit is really
sort of natural and straightforward so
actually there's a good example of this
in the in the quill white paper that
sort of uses the QFT is as a primary
example with sort of python pseudocode
that shows how to sort of recursively
build up a circuit yeah
classical it's got it yes it's classical
or quantum recursion it's good classical
quantum occur Jean is Harry
repeat delicious
so the question was whether you how much
control you have over the classical
protocol right for the schedule yeah
yeah so what we actually provide is a
way to actually use any classical
optimizer if you want to run the
algorithm in that mode and we do allow
you to do any kind of order of the
algorithm so any so given maybe Suzuki
charter version one you can do any kind
of number of steps of that and so what I
showed was elbow one and then we jumped
all the way to five for this example but
you can do it at any order we do have
functionality for doing other up to five
fifth orders as you each other if you'd
like and just and from like a structural
standpoint like one of the ways that
these vqe loops work is they like you
can put in any quill program any pipes
in any pipe or program as you're on sots
there's no restrictions on what you put
in and we have this kind of thing you
can load stuff in the documentation it's
too much to say now but we have this
notion of a parametric Pikeville program
which is like a template for a quantum
circuit where you can then like
variation we fill in parameters and this
is this comes in really handy cool all
right and so when you guys you can pull
out laptops now and and if we jump into
the browser and you guys go to forest
regatta calm slash notebooks and you'll
get access to a bunch of notebooks that
show both you know there's one that runs
the quill native code in it there's
things that run maxcut there's things
that run vqe and there's some some kind
of cool examples to play in and the sign
in is just your your email and the
password is a capital Q IP 2017 so I can
walk you through that to do and we'll
see how much the conference Internet
holds up there's also one more thing
that I want to show you guys so if you
do not have your laptops with you you
can also tweet to run a quantum
computation either on the qvm or if
you're me on the real thing
so at quill bot is live on twitter if
you do a quill bot and give it a quill
program it will run it for you you can
fit it in 140 characters and tweet back
if you're me
and you tweet at it it'll run on that
same qubit on that same chip that I was
demoing earlier and so this is oh my
syntax was maybe wrong
we'll find out so this is the the exact
same thing I was running in the
Pikeville notebook but just through
Twitter so if you want to run and make a
superposition state using my phone using
Twitter come up and grab me because
that's fun also if you guys need any
help or if you have questions about and
about what you're looking at in the
notebooks there's there's several of us
here what kind of what kind of disperse
around a bunch of my colleagues know
this stuff really well we've got drinks
in the back I think we're out of cheese
and but at this point you know ask
questions and have fun and thanks thanks
very much for your attention
[Applause]